The final area.
We're going to discuss the concerns reproduction has to do with the difficulties
that a shift in our posture brought for childbirth.
Human childbirth is extremely difficult because the pelvis has been modified for
upright by Peter Walking.
Maternal mortality has only recently declined in developed countries and it
remains high in undeveloped countries,
so there is a real cost to childbirth is dangerous from others.
The female pelvis constraints bur brain size at birth,
and it also means that in order to get through the birth canal,
the infant head must rotate and it can exit directly in chimpanzees.
Most human infants are therefore born facing backwards,
whereas in other primates they are born facing forward.
This means that the mother is not in as good a position to help clear the baby's
nostrils and help it breathe when it first comes out.
So this may imply that females have had assistance during birth for a very long
time in our evolutionary history.
Now first,
let's take a look at maternal mortality.
So this is maternal deaths per 100,000 this is a log scale over here.
Maternal deaths from other causes are staying fairly steady,
but from puerperal fever,
maternal death started to decline in the 30s and that's gone down nearly to zero
as a result of antibiotic use.
So much of the decline from poor portal fever,
which is the infection that can result in the uterus after childbirth
has been controlled by antibiotics,
but maternal mortality remains significant in developing countries.
So internal childbirth is costly.
It's a risky business.
The difficulty in human childbirth results both from the fact that we now walk
upright.
You can see the remodeling here of the hip,
which is indicated in orange,
and the fact that our brains have increased in size and our babies have large
heads,
so it is harder for a baby to get through the human pelvis than it is for a
chimpanzee offspring to get through the chimpanzee pelvis.
Bye.
Pete Elysium preceded the narrow birth canal.
We know that Sahil anthropics was probably by peatal about 7 million years ago.
Australopithecus was by peatal and it was small brain.
It was probably frugivorous.
Okay.
The narrow birth canal in Homo habilis about 2 million years ago.
Now
if we take,
if we look at the cranium of an infant in the birth canal,
it's sketched here in gray and the diameter of the birth canal is sketched in
light orange.
What we see is the infant cranium could not be any larger and still fit in the
birth canal.
It is stretching the birth canal to its limits.
The rotation of the infant head during birth suggested health has at birth has
long been needed.
Okay,
so bipedalism originated in Australopithecus or earlier and the rotation of the
infant head in the birth canal causes humans to be born facing backward.
In other primates,
the mother can actually reach down and clean the nose of the infant to help it
because it is being born facing forward so she can actually look down at it as
it is coming out of the birth canal and cleanout its nostrils.
Human Mothers and infants then benefit from uh,
having a midwife or Duaner at birth who can catch the baby and clean its nose.
So there is evidence in our own pattern birth of our increased sociality.
And this could very well be done by sisters,
aunts or grandmothers.
It's notable that human brains are actually small at birth relative to their
adult size.
So they're big in the sense that they completely fill the birth canal,
but there's small relative to how large they're going to be in an ETL.
So despite pushing the limits of the birth canal,
human brains are still much smaller at birth relative to their adult size than
are those of other primates.
They continue to grow after birth more than do the brains of other primates.
That period of post postnatal brain growth,
it lasts until about age seven and it defines this developmental period we call
childhood that does not occur in other great apes.
Yeah,
because brain growth is essential and it requires fat.
This is one reason why human infants contained so much fat at birth.
Human infants are actually is fat or fatter than BB elephant seals at birth.
So to summarize,
upright posture,
which evolved four to 7 million years ago,
along with rapid long distance pursuit of prey,
which evolved about two to 3 million years ago,
led to a remodeling of the pelvis,
which constrained size at birth,
primarily size of the cranium,
and thus of the brain.
Okay.
Selection to increase.
Infant size of birth is being balanced by selection,
acting through maternal mortality in childbirth.
There trade offs between the health and the development of the infant and the
survival of the infant in the mother.
These morphological constraints have contributed to the evolution of the
uniquely long human childhood during which the brain grows to adult size.